I just saw a video from a creator I really like
talking about how annoyed she is by online feminists
who make disparaging remarks about being a stay at home mom.
And she used the sort of indignation to talk to feminists
and say that feminism is just about supporting every woman's identity
and wholeness and choice,
whether that is somebody who gets an education or is a boss bitch
or decides to be a stay at home mom and homemaker
and just aspires to have children and be a wife.
And I first wanna validate people who feel this way.
I have seen the rhetoric online
that extremely devalues the labor of mothers
and homemakers especially um.
And it can feel really,
really frustrating and disappointing to see women trying
kind of tear each other down based on their lifestyle choices.
However, I'm extremely critical of people who wanna push this idea
that women have true choice in this country,
because what we have in America truly is the illusion of choice.
And I don't think that we are doing our younger sisters,
our women who have yet to become mothers,
any service
by alluding to the fact that this is a true and equitable choice,
whether to work or to stay home with children.
But I know a lot of women who have come to this lifestyle,
myself included, who now find great satisfaction in it,
who came to this choice,
this choice through economic or career inequality.
We have not gone far enough in this country
in order to have this understanding that it is a true choice.
We have not gone far enough because we still don't have a true,
equitable life for working women mothers.
We still don't have things like a reasonable maternal health system.
We don't have things like a reasonable length of a maternity leave.
We don't have things like subsidized child care.
We don't have things like programs that support young families.
We don't have things like daycare in offices we don't even have.
Or we are just starting to put in legislation
that secures and codifies a woman's right to have clean,
sanitary and private place to pump for her child.
That just happened.
Employers were still able to fire their pregnant employees.
I have held enough hands of my crying friends
to know that 12 weeks is not a reasonable amount of time
for a new mother to spend with her infant child.
A great example of this is Germany
that I know, I think has three years,
which allows women to take that time necessary to spend
to raise their child from infancy
and still have an opportunity to go back to work
when and if they are ready.
And of course, not every woman is gonna Wanna do that.
Some women are going to truly choose to stay home with her children.
But doesn't that seem like more of an actual choice?
This country does not support Mothers or children.
Because if they did, they would allow for that.
We would fund that.
Because we all know that healthy mothers and children are together
for at least the first year of that baby's life.
In order to promote things like maternal bonding and breastfeeding.
And in order to actually have healthy children and healthy mothers,
we have to give them actual healthy choices.
So when the criticism comes,
we get defensive. We say, no,
this is my choice.
Because we have found satisfaction and love for the job that we do,
and we value the labor that we do,
and we should.
But the criticism doesn't come for the life that we're leading.
It comes from the belief that we actually had a true
and valid and equitable choice.
Because what we have really gotten is a piece of coal in a stocking,
and we're calling it a Christmas present.
Women in this country don't actually have a choice.
What we have is a system that is gonna depend
on so many of us not liking the choices we have
and choosing to stay home
because it is easier, it is more natural,
and it is better for our children.
Because women are the backbone,
and the unpaid labor are the backbone of our economy.
And if we gave women equitable choice,
we would actually have to prioritize children and pay for that.
It's not about whose identity is more valid.
It is about setting up the Women
who have not yet gotten to this phase of life
to realize that they are already in a losing position
because we have not given them what would be required
to make an equitable choice
to stay or not stay in the labor force.